- But you, you've actually,
you've delivered babies
on the show, so, what,
what were the births
of your own kids like?
Were they intense?
I was so ready to get mine out.
I was just get out, get out, get out.
- Yes, oh, yes.
Well, my son was huge.
He was humongous and I feel
like the hippies lied to me,
because I was watching these documentaries
about these water births
and they were all, you know,
doing this, like, (groaning)
they were just, I was like,
wow, this I can do that.
I can do that, I wanna do a water birth.
So I go to this hospital
where they actually
allow water births in the
hospital but my water breaks
at five in the morning, pop!
I literally felt it break.
I was like, oh my water broke.
Then the labor just
started coming really fast
and so I didn't have time to
stop, like, my husband's like
watch TV, it'll be hours,
it's your first baby,
we don't know, so, no, no, no.
So we're driving and I'm
like in whatever transition
in the car, I think.
By the time I get to the
hospital, I'm nine centimeters
and so I push for two hours
out of the birthing tub,
screaming bloody murder.
- Oh, god!
- And I was like,
he's stuck, he's stuck!
I kept waiting for somebody to
be like, oh, we have to take
him out of you via Cesarean,
emergency C-section!
And I was like, nobody's
coming and I'm still pushing.
And then they get the tub set up
and it didn't really seem
to make a difference, unfortunately.
(laughing)
And I finally got him out
and he was like nine pounds.
And so, oh yeah, he was big baby.
Big, big, big baby and
so when I got pregnant
with my daughter, I got a epidural.
- Oh amen.
(laughing and applause)
- I did, I did.
- Oh!
- And it was a beautiful
experience with like magical,
because I, I should've
listened to my two friends.
Two of my best friends had babies
and they were like, girl, get
the epidural, don't be stupid.
If you're gonna take Tylenol
or Motrin for a headache
you're gonna need the good drugs.
And it was a beautiful
experience with her.
I pushed her out in 20 minutes
and she was the glorious
happy baby, and...
- Dude, I'll tell you what.
- So, yeah.
- It, I had friends tell me as well,
there were, there were
several different ideas
of what, you know, should
happen for your birth.
And I was like, if God intended
for me to not have drugs
and not have help getting this out
then he wouldn't have had me born in 1982.
- Word, word.
- Because I am gonna take,
what are you, what can you put in here
to make it less hurtful?
I was like, give me every,
the baby will be fine.
I was like, does this make you want
to just pop some children out?
- No, it doesn't.
- Is it just like,
birth control, what just happened?
- Yep! Thank you!